[Music]
so far away but it's coming so fast okay
how do you pronounce the town that you
guys from Collini
call me
Turner complete rework 8:1
my mom's a strong woman I can't imagine
being in that situation like she was and
having to overcome all those obstacles
that she did
honestly don't know how she did it
that's why she's like a hero does we
have so much love for our mom we do
truly understand that we definitely
wouldn't be here with her that's why
everything that we do now is you know is
for her and for family
[Music]
we were in a small town it was really
tough as a single parent having
interracial children made it a lot worse
I had a black boyfriend an interracial
child at the time and they just wasn't
accepted
Nevada forwards Cody and Caleb Martin
grew up in Kula mean North Carolina a
town located about 40 minutes southwest
of winston-salem once a thriving Mill
Village the area is known for its
deep-seated racism
[Music]
you wake up there's the Sunday morning
and you look outside there's no one
there that there's no one out there but
there's a cross that that was burned
yeah the thoughts that are going through
your mind or how did this happen you
don't even know even any point fearful
of not only just your life but also um a
little bit like not I was and I wasn't
you know you just don't know what's what
could happen yeah it was scary
you're thinking what's next man set your
house on fire or you know where they try
to do something to your children when
you're not there phenomenally like the
racist area just because it's a small
town so everybody knows everything the
mix of 20 races it was just kind of
crazy how like you go from you weren't
accepted because you're with a black guy
you know I'm a white area then you know
at first and then it you're like kind of
an outcast you didn't want white there
all round it up phenomenally black
[Music]
when you hear her telling you stories
about a burning cross as she wakes up or
walks outside of her door what goes
through your mind confesses you all a
little bit just just because and dealing
with discrimination like all this stuff
it's like people just really I know it's
worth playing and it's like for her to
really fight through adversity and kind
of persevere like it's it's crazy to see
her do that these are people that live
in the same community that you live in
some are ones that look at you day to
day and it was very scary we were just
driving and they just try to swerve it
and make you just run off the road in
here throwing out slurs or whatever out
the window and then you know kind of
swerve to like try to run you over while
you're walking and you pretty much have
to kind of jump over to a side and this
is ridiculous we had to take the trash
out in pairs here to take trash out twos
make sure nothing happening make sure we
was safe
you try to put it back in the back your
mind and not think about it not dwell on
it but you just know hatred was real it
is real and you know you just have to
prepare your children for that
a prejudiced environment wasn't the only
challenge Jenny Bennett and her three
children faced the family lived in
poverty and feared for its life
surrounded by violence related to drug
dealing sacrifices were made that the
Martin twins didn't realize until they
were older insects the bugs and stuff
and in the trailer and did not have any
money and like not even realizing that
you know that my mom's not eating so we
can eat I was Section eight and we had a
single-wide trailer and it was it had
roaches and there was rats it was awful
I had two or three jobs and and I just
you know I did what I had to do and and
you know sometimes I didn't eat she
sound not hungry all days you went you
sound not homey
we eat and then there would be nothing
left so then she just like would eat
she's the one who's working she's the
one making the money and she's coming
back
paying for it and see you're not even
heat it so it's like that stuff you
don't notice you look back you like then
that's why there's so much appreciation
in love for my mom and putting us first
I was so unselfish growing up around
racism and poverty the Martin twins
needed an outlet
[Music]
what role did basketball have in their
childhood they kept him focused kept him
motivated gave them and out and that was
a release for them no no we had to
figure out a way to help her out at some
point and that's when we got our first
jobs and during basketball season we
worked at Walmart we're a car pushers we
want to make a lot of money but like
we'd make enough to where we could pay
for gas and food so it kind of takes
something off her plate it brought them
closer together and yeah it wasn't the
best of situations but I think that's
what made them because they are really
close I love that I love that they love
each other when they all get together
they still wrestle around the floor as
old as they are and it's ridiculous I
[Music]
wouldn't have it any other way
the reality is they couldn't had anybody
loved them more than me for sure how
much does that looking back on
everything everything because I him who
I am because of them
I don't know where I would be without
them sure mom Jenny Bennett cheering on
this Wolf Pack come back that's why we
go so hard I think that's why we you
know when we play we play with a lot of
passion and we're trying to hopefully
put ourselves and my mom and I found me
in a best situation to where they don't
have the way
[Applause]
[Music]
hey it's Master here with Br please
subscribe to check out some more great
video content